cuáles de las siguientes funciones son
continuas para todos los números reales
así que primero qué te parece si
recordamos que es una función continua y
para eso voy a dibujar por acá a mis
ejes supongamos que este es mi game y
por acá tengo a mi eje
x ok y vamos a poner sus nombres este es
mi eje que este de por aquí es mi eje x
ok y una función va a ser continua
durante un intervalo si no tiene saltos
o discontinuidades o huecos sobre dicho
intervalo así que si está conectada o la
podemos dibujar sin despegar el lápiz
por ejemplo esta de aquí esta sería una
función continua entonces observa que no
tiene ningún hueco está conectada
durante todo el intervalo en donde
buscábamos continuidad ahora si te
preguntas en algún ejemplo de una
función que sea discontinua en algún
intervalo o alguna función no continua
bueno podríamos tener alguna función que
tenga un hueco o una discontinuidad de
algún tipo podremos tener por ejemplo
una discontinuidad asintótica que se
viera más o menos
esta tendría un tipo de discontinuidad
asintótica pero no es mi único tipo de
discontinuidad también podríamos tener
alguna discontinuidad donde hagamos
algún salto en él por ejemplo aquí
tenemos una función que va bien feliz
por aquí y de repente salta y vuelve a
aparecer por acá y continúa
o se me ocurre una función que solamente
tenga un hueco en algún lado por ejemplo
una función que vaya aquí tengo un hueco
y después continúe tan campante por la
vida o tal vez tenga un hueco pero sea
una discontinuidad extraíble es decir
que la función esté definida en otro
valor así que todas estas son gráficas
de funciones discontinuas ahora si
quieres una interpretación más
matemática de todo esto podemos decir
que una función f es continua en un
cierto valor
supongamos en a si sólo se observa si
sólo si se representa como una línea con
dos flechas sí sólo si el límite
límite cuando x tiende a am de fx
efe de x esto es exactamente igual a efe
de a esta es nuestra definición más
matemática y observa una vez que quieras
pedirle a esta función que sea continua
en f
tienes que estar definida en f y ahora
cuando vemos estas opciones
lo primero que veo es que gtx esta
función no está definida para todos los
números reales porque lo que buscamos es
una función que esté definida para todos
los números reales y gtx no está
definida para valores negativos así que
no puedo cancelar esta no es nuestra
opción correcta y ahora pensemos en fx
fx igual
a la equis y bueno esta si está definida
para todos los números reales porque
como veremos la mayoría de las funciones
comunes que hemos aprendido en
matemáticas no tienen huecos ni saltos
ni discontinuidades algunas la tienen
como la función 1 / x o funciones
similares pero las funciones como la x
en definitiva no tienen ninguna
discontinuidad podríamos graficar aquí a
fx igual a la equis y se vería más o
menos así es una función que está
definida para todos los números reales y
en definitiva no tiene saltos ni huecos
ni nada así así que la respuesta
correcta es solo efe
y ya sé que no hice una prueba muy
rigurosa ustedes podrían hacerla si
gustan pero el motivo de este ejercicio
es realmente obtener un sentido
intuitivo de cómo se puede ver esta
función a la equis y ver que en
definitiva está definida para todos los
números reales ya que observa no tiene
saltos ni huecos y así es más que
razonable decir que es una función
continua pero si gustan podrían ser
también una prueba más rigurosa